so we are going to be working on some
graphs today but to help you get some
intuition for why the graphs that we're
looking at are going to be the exact
nature of those graphs I want to remind
you or reintroduce you to this guy now
we started thinking out trigonometry at
first in the context of triangles which
kind of makes sense trigonometry
trigonometry yeah I mean you've got the
three right at the front of the name
right anyone know what the gone means
eyes in polygons right so this is this
is a shape it's gone actually means
angle specifically so polygon is middie
angled so you got a three angled
actually might be three-sided anyway
just matter
you're gonna triangle right out the
front and then this just means you're
about measuring them right which is
unsurprising we started thinking about
trigonometry in the context of these
guys we were like find a side find an
angle etc right but we quickly realize
that further we went into this that
triangles weren't going to cut it for
example in a right angle triangle let's
have a look at these other two angles
here right what is the largest that an
angle in a right angle triangle can be
that's the largest either of these could
be it has to be less than 90 right
because you've already taken 90 degrees
there or we could say pilot Iranians and
the whole triangle is only going to be a
hundred and eighty degrees or PI radians
so what you've got left for your other
two angles is pretty small but angles go
way past 90 degrees they go way plus PI
on two if we start over here at the
horizontal you're gonna have to put this
on yourself in a minute for them do
they're really not doing it yet we can
go up to here that gives you your 90
degrees you're part two but then there's
kind of all the rests of these angles
over here if you're doing bearings or
things like that we frequently have
angles that are bigger than acute in
size so we decided we can have to break
out of these right angle triangles
that's why we introduced the unit circle
now to get an idea of what this is going
to look like you have all picked up one
of these I hope so this is your set of
axes which we're going to use I've put
in some markings there but I was a
little bit lazy because it was quite
hard to do on the computer so you can
see I've got markings every one and a
half centimeters
going to encourage you it'll be more
useful to you if you put in an extra
double the number of markings that are
there so see how you've got one half
cent centimeter breaks I'd break every
single one of them also into half so
that would be seven half milliliters I
guess now what do each of these
horizontal things measure well what I'd
like you to label where's my pen I've
put it down somewhere well I'd like you
to label the horizontal axis with saris
that'll do is with feet ah we're going
to measure angles across this horizontal
axis so all the way over here we usually
call this horizontal axis like X that's
usually on the Cartesian plane that's
all we would call it but I'm interested
in angles let's call this theta over
here so you could mark it in like so
now even though we've got radians in our
head for now I've given you a number of
markings and it's gonna be easier for
you numerically to think about this as
degrees so I hope I have given you
enough markings once you've put in those
extra lines I hope you've got enough
markings for one sort of - every 10
degrees roughly okay which corresponds
lovely to this all right now if you have
a look just eyeball it right you can see
as you go around there are 36 divisions
of this circle right so each one
represents ten degrees and when you've
got this piece of paper in fact you know
what I'm gonna distribute them now I
only have another one between two but
that's because you only need one between
two so I'm gonna pass them off that way
so yeah I've still got my own can you
pass off I might take a couple off the
front sorry sorry all this what we
should impose is the Cartesian plane
that we've seen before now just looking
at carefully you can see there's gonna
be that one that goes straight up so I'm
gonna put that in like so it's going to
go all the way to the middle you of
course would use a ruler I just didn't
bring mine with me and if that's our
vertical axis right up then you can see
where the horizontal axis should sit I
think mine is going to be this line here
okay so this is my my rough and dirty
version now remember what we did was we
redefined the trigonometric ratios sine
and cosine instead of being you know
opposite on hypotenuse or any such
combination within a right angle
triangle what we said was we can
describe sine and cosine as the
coordinates of points on the unit circle
okay
so remember how I told you there are 36
divisions how far have I rotated up from
the horizontal axis if I get to there
this is one division which is how many
degrees in this case ten degrees right
so I you don't have to mark this in by
the way but I'm going to do this just so
you can see it here that's ten degrees
okay now what we're saying is that sine
of ten degrees for example sine of ten
degrees is that the vertical corner or
the horizontal coordinate sign think
about it sine cosine sine cosine which
one is which one of the easiest way to
remember is that it's alphabetical so
you know how it's in Cartesian
coordinates it's X comma Y that's
alphabetical
well it's alphabetical conveniently here
as well cause called a sign in fact I'm
gonna write that down cos theta and then
sine theta so if I'm interested in sine
of 10 degrees sine of ten degrees is the
y coordinate of that spot right there
the y coordinate now here's the way
we're going to measure it I have some
spaghetti here right so I can take my
spaghetti my sphere is a bit too long at
the moment I want spaghetti that
represents that y-coordinate see that
the Y coordinates how high are you above
the x axis so I'm going to do my very
best
I'm going to encourage you to do this on
your your spaghetti as well that's so
that I remember where the spot is so
there you go you can see that little
tiny red mark all right let's see how
accurate I am everybody that was pretty
close a little bit off but I'm okay with
that you can see I can put that there
like so stay put spaghetti there yeah
all right can you see it next to my
finger okay we'll get this long out one
now the weight don't need this right
okay now you have your Cartesian plane
they're not Cartesian plane you're where
you're going to put your angles on this
right
so this this leg in my hand this is sign
of 10 degrees on my circle so I'm going
to place it wherever 10 degrees would be
I think I asked you to put in markings
every let's make that horizontal for you
every half way like so so 10 degrees is
gonna be right there okay
now hopefully most of you should have
one of these on your table and you won't
need I'll give you mine in a sec exactly
I will tell you right now when you're
putting your spaghetti on because you
don't have a flat object I contemplate
it usually fettuccine but it would take
out too much space you're going to use a
fair bit of this because there's not a
huge amount of surface it's a round
thing that you're trying to stick on
right so be liberal I'm going to go
ahead and check on Lots don't worry it's
gonna dry so I'm gonna put it in like so
all right there's my first one okay now
one of most important phrases in all
cookie shows because we're dealing with
spaghetti is here's what I prepared
earlier up now I haven't I'm not gonna
spoil it for you but this is what it
starts to look like right the first
one's 10 degrees and they're 20 and then
xxx at 40 you've got 36 markings to do
now between the two of you the reason
why you have to separate ones
is not to do the same graph I would like
one of you to do sign like we're doing
right here and then the other one I'd
like you to do cosign right and I'll let
you choose but remember what you have
you look at this right sign is how high
you are what's cosine its how how far
across it's the x-coordinate right so
what I'm gonna do
let's have a look at this guy there
there is my ex corde you see that right
there that's how far across I am now
this bits a little bit tricky when you
get this particular length I'm gonna
mark that right there let's see how good
my snapping is yeah I could do better
than that but that's good there's my
there's my horizontal me that's cosine
right but when you put this onto your
graph because we're graphing this with
our feet is going this way and this is
going to be where we do the function
right so this is our sine theta R cosine
theta even though I measured this
horizontally when I put it on my graph
I'm gonna put it vertically and that's a
bit funny but I've given you exactly the
right side so hopefully it should fit
okay